what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can't decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
okay so one of the most common requests
that I have is to make a video on the
origin of Hulk 2099 that is to say the
Marvel 2099 version of The Incredible
Hulk now the reason why this is a
different iteration is because the 2099
imprint under Marvel was designed to
give us an idea of what the world would
look like in 2099 I mean it's really
kind of speaks for itself
but the difference here is that for the
most part everything's changed there are
a couple similarities and there are
actually some teams that are still the
same for example if it was Fantastic
Four 2099 but that was a last-ditch
effort to keep the imprint of flow
despite floundering sales and it was
just a time displaced Fantastic Four
team but like Doctor Doom with doom 2099
was actually Victor Von Doom so I mean
there were things that were still
familiar there but like spider-man 2099
was a guy named Miguel O'Hara and
credible Hulk is a guy named John
Eisenhart now his initial appearance
actually does not come out of his own
solo series and that's one of the big
misconceptions people have and it's
understandable because not a lot of
people are aware of the concept of
anthology series if you're new to comic
books what most publishers do at least
what they did do when they were first
coming onto the scene is they would just
launch a whole ton of anthology books
and in follow G books are basically just
comics that tell a whole bunch of
different stories they're all just B's
you know five six seven page independent
stories isolated from anything else and
that's it for example the original flash
Jay Garrick made his appearance in the
flash comics but it was just like flash
Comics number one I think it was I mean
it was just you know Jay Garrick the
flash and like a whole bunch of other
stories Superman as most anybody knows
made his appearance at Action Comics
number one but he was just one of
several stories in that comic book when
it came to Detective Comics Batman made
his appearance there and he was just one
of several stories now usually an
anthology series will be spun out into a
solo series if there's like a standout
star so for example journey into mystery
focused on a lot of different things
weird kooky crazy things but Thor was
the most popular character in that title
and so what eventually happened is
journey into mystery was just
transformed into Thor's own solo series
the name was kept for a time and then
eventually journey into mystery just
became Thor so that's what Marvel
usually does that's what DC's done on a
multitude of occasions Bravin the bowl
is where we first
got Teen Titans this one refers Scott
the Suicide Squad team extra I'm sorry
Task Force X different things like that
but what this story does is it actually
runs as part of a second feature with
spider-man 2099 and so that's one of the
reasons why if you look that up it'll
sake the premiere of The Hulk and if for
some miraculous reason or another you
get your hands with a physical copy
you'll start coming through and the
first thing you'll see is find a man
2099 because it's an anthology series
but the fact remains the Marvel 2099
landscape was designed to focus on in a
world really on the United States where
corporations just ran everything it was
just this extreme corporate attitude
where corporations controlled everything
but did so in a multitude of different
ways for example one of the things this
deals with with John Eisenhart is that
he's basically like this lawyer this guy
that goes through on behalf of movie
studios works out deals and then does it
extremely aggressive tricking people
selling their rights without them
knowing it tricking them into bad
contracts so on and so forth just for
the purpose of making sure that these
production studios gain money but the
idea here is that filmmaking as we know
which is you going to a movie theater
watching movies that's a thing of the
past now it's all virtual reality you
plan a virtual reality helmet and you
watch that film by yourself but you feel
like you're actually there so it's kind
of cool here but what this initially
does is it focuses on this idea that
Java 2 previously worked out a deal only
the habit just kind of pulled out from
under and that's really kind of how that
goes but what this initially emphasizes
is what's called the warrior mentality
and that's actually going to directly
juxtapose the traditional warrior
mentality as we think of it and it's
kind of cool in terms of powell this
gets done but jumping into this what
ends up happening is this movie studio
had basically learned of a group that
were called the knights of manor and
initially nobody really knew what these
knights of banner were about there was
just kind of rumors what this does is it
emphasizes the idea that this warrior
mentality of john john Eisenhart goes
directly against the warrior mentality
of the knights of manor these are a
group of guys who basically just broke
off away from the main United States
government or United States society
because they hated the you know
corporate mentality and just began
taking up traditional honorable warrior
mentalities but they model themselves
after Bruce Banner the funny thing about
this is that Jon doesn't know this
initially instead what he does is he
pops up and says hey look you know I can
basically take all the rights to the
Knights of banner
concept and then sell it to a movie
studio and these guys get absolutely
nothing but when is it happening if
these guys actually turn on and say no
like we don't want to have anything to
do with that we want to have this
traditional Warriors mentality now the
funny thing about this is that on the
whole they are the minority they are a
small number of people they're the last
bastion of the way things used to be
there are people out there who wish to
return back to the way things were but
for the most part they're few and far
between the idea here is that with John
being turned down what he ends up doing
is trying to filter through and sort out
their weakness and as it comes with any
organized society whatsoever the
weakness is always the kids if you
control the kids
you control the pimp and so what is it
happening here is John comes across this
kid named Gawain and grains basically
just as kid who dreams of you know life
in the big city that kind of a thing
it's really interesting because what
this does is it hits on small-town life
in comparison to the big city I don't
have maybe guys live in a small town as
opposed to a major metropolitan area
like Los Angeles or Seattle or Dallas or
something along those lines but a lot of
people know me especially living in a
smaller town like Lexington like I did
for you know 20 years you always dream
of like the bigger life I wonder what
Los Angeles is like I wonder what New
York City is like but with the idea of
this particular scenario Dwayne looks at
all this and says it's my chance to see
the bright city likes it's my chance to
see how everything could be as opposed
to living in this small little rural
isolated area in this traditional
fashion now what Dwayne does is he
basically spills the beans on everything
about the about the Knights abandoned
and what he ends up saying is that the
entire group hails and they really model
themselves after Bruce Banner himself
more so than that after the Incredible
Hulk concept the problem with this as
John states is that for the most part
any kind of messing around or anything
that has to do with gamma radiation has
basically been outlawed now there were a
couple reasons for this one of which
John Hitz at and the other we could just
kind of go on our own and sort of take
it from there one of the most notable is
the idea that gamma rays were just too
unpredictable I mean John really kind of
points out the idea that people who are
blasted with gamma radiation react in
different ways and no one really knows
how they're going to turn out the
Incredible Hulk is a really good example
under normal circumstances the
Incredible Hulk just couldn't be
controlled and a lot of it was because
of how the Hulk viewed the world I mean
you have to
in mind imagine that you have split
personalities and imagine that one
personality just takes over but you're
going to have these giant chunks in your
mind well you're not going to remember
anything that happened because you
weren't the dominant personality you
can't access the memories of that
personality it's almost like your mind
is compartmentalized and there are rooms
that you just can't access when it came
to Bruce Banner and when it came to be
Incredible Hulk the idea was that when
Bruce Banner was in control the
Incredible Hulk depending on who was
writing the story at the time would not
remember anything Bruce Banner was doing
when the Incredible Hulk was dominant
Bruce Banner would not remember anything
the Incredible Hulk had done now the
reason why I say different riders is
because some writers take certain
liberties some writers say well Bruce
Banner is always subconsciously keeping
the Hulk in check and so he always know
is what it is of the Hulk is doing other
times there's been stories like World
War Hulk for example where Bruce Banner
in the Incredible Hulk both agree on the
hoax ideology and Bruce Banner just kind
of relinquished his control but then if
you go back and you read Incredible Hulk
stories from the 80s from the 90s the
ideas of Bruce Banner doesn't know what
the Hulk is doing the other half of this
equation is that when it comes to the
Marvel 2099 universe or I guess the this
future The Last Man Standing the Lone
Gunmen the one guy who's willing to
stand up to everything it's something
that can't be tolerated and the reason
why is because all it takes is one
person to inspire an army of people one
person to be a martyr it takes that one
guy who's willing to stand up and say
the world we're living in is not the way
things should be we're living in this
dark sinister place where corporations
run everything we have to take them down
corporations will respond by killing him
that guy becomes a martyr and suddenly
these corporations have to battle all of
society who stands up and says yeah that
guy was right things don't need to be
this way and so if you nip all that in
the bud you keep people like you know
Captain America Steve Rogers from you
know popping up or sending them on those
lines then ultimately what you do is you
quell any possible martyr that anybody's
willing to pay attention to because
remember people will only follow those
who actually have a chance to succeed
and so because of this with this
particular story what Jon does is go
back and basically just begin the
process of trying to find a way to
figure out how to gain this concept of
the Knights of Manor the what also ends
up taking place here is he actually
finds out that because of the fact that
the leader of the Knights of banner are
conducting these gamma radiation
experiments in an attempt to recreate
the Incredible Hulk they're effectively
breaking
the law and so what this will do is it
will basically allow John to report then
to his top person to audre I think her
name is the one that runs Lotus head
Studios the thing is what it's called
and then in turn have this group called
sweet dreams a security force more or
less go through and arrest the Knights
of banner ill in turn allowed John to
basically take everything they have to
literally remove them from the equation
learn everything about them and then
while they're rotting in jail never to
be seen or heard from again
basically capitalize on everything
they've built and so what this does is
it actually switches over for a second
to a girl named quark now quark is not
really important for the sake of this
story but it is kind of a cool thing to
point out here because this again hits
home at the idea that not everybody's
happy about everything that's going on
about the current world they live in
this corporate attitude where
corporations run virtually everything
but we also end up finding out is that
in the songs that she's been releasing
these corporations have been throwing in
subliminal messaging and so we're court
herself is basically thrown in this idea
of saying hey look I'm singing songs
where I'm talking about standing up to
the system when I'm talking about
walking away from the way things need to
be overthrowing all these corporations
this hits home at her her love of the
1990s and what she actually does is draw
on names like Madonna ice-t and the
reason for this is because of the fact
that Madonna was very rebellious for her
time she will just kind of took women
who normally not really walked these
traditional roles but basically said hey
look go do what you want when you want
how you want when it came to iced tea
iced tea made songs where he talked
about life in the inner city I mean
there are a lot of different things a
lot of different songs were coming out
of this time assuming made people feel
uncomfortable they made them feel a
little off because it went against the
view of the world that they had at the
time and so because of that this girl
quirk is trying to bring that entire
concept that the problem with this is
that she's not singing songs out to a
society that may or may not listen she's
singing songs out to his corporations
that are actively trying to quell
sentiment just like that and so what
this does is this basically continues to
bring down a massive amount of heat
until it gets to the point where
corporations have had enough and so what
ended up happening here is John
Eisenhart basically came to the
realization that this sweet dream
security force was tasked with the role
of taking out quark now what does does
is this coincides with John's desire to
basically solve all these problems to
fix all these things because what this
ends up doing is it really kind
jumps back to the modern day what we end
up finding out is that this segment of
the story actually deals with him once
he's already The Incredible Hulk from
2099 now the idea here and the reason
why he's basically taking up this role
to protect this girl named quark goes
back to when he first became hooked 2099
in the first place and what we end up
finding out is that his intention to
report the nights of banner to sweet
dreams
was designed to basically have them
arrested but to have them arrested
peacefully what is up happening here is
it the Knights of Banner actually stand
up and say we will not go without a
fight
and this basically leads to an absolute
bloodbath the sweet dream security force
kills them all now this is the
motivation for why it is that Jon
decides to save quark because he's seen
what happens when sweet dreams is tasked
with going in and just eliminating a
threat they kill everyone
they don't take prisoners they kill them
all anybody who's around that general
vicinity anybody who could be a witness
they'll end up getting killed and so
because of this the only person who
really survives this massive you know
massacre is Gawain himself and in an
attempt to basically get revenge for you
know the death of the various members of
the Knights of banner the winners of
happening here as he races back to this
you know experimental machine with
regards to this gamma radiation and of
course John follows him John grabs and
pushes him out of the way and John's
blasted with gamma radiation and so what
this does is it transforms him into the
Hulk from 2099
now one thing to keep in mind when it
comes to Marvel releasing a different
iteration of a character they always try
to find some way to make them different
and the reason why is because of the
fact that if they had just transformed
John Eisenhart into the Incredible Hulk
and he was basically identical to the
Incredible Hulk from the main Marvel
Universe from the modern day readers
wouldn't really have a reason to check
it out you know their philosophy would
most likely be if I'm going to read a
story about the Incredible Hulk
I'm going to read the one I know about
not the one that I don't know about and
so because of this Marvel gave a few
differences of course the physical
appearance is one of the most striking
differences between John Eisenhart Hulk
and Bruce Banner Hulk but some of the
other differences here is the mentality
whenever John Eisenhart transforms into
the Incredible Hulk which he can do it
will he maintains his mental faculties
now as time progressed that began to go
away Marvel began to bring John
Eisenhart closer in line with the
classic Incredible Hulk which basically
resulted in a fractured psyche the
difference here is that unlike Bruce
Banner who's largely just kind of trying
to make his way and be a
good guy and The Incredible Hulk cuckoo
who may or may not be a good guy
depending on the story The Hulk 2099 was
actually a good guy and John Eisenhart
basically became this ruthless villain
in a lot of different ways and so the
result of this is that in this moment
when he transforms into Hulk 2099 and
realizes the power that he possessed he
literally becomes a one-man wrecking
crew much like the classic banner
Incredible Hulk
John Eisenhart strength increases as he
gets angrier and so that remains the
same that part keeps going his
invulnerability is almost on par with
the classic Incredible Hulk his healing
factor almost on par with the classic
Incredible Hulk and a lot of ways they
are almost identical and so because of
this in this moment what this does is it
leads to court watching all these events
unfold this massive attack this massive
explosion when he shows up after
intending to basically rescue her take
her away
and when the questions ask who are you
he simply says I'm just a man and so
what this does is this actually
continues on for the next five issues of
Marvel 2099 unlimited again the whole
idea was to basically use it as an
anthology series hi spider-man into it
who is the most popular 2099 character
at the time give people exposure to Hulk
2099 and then spin him out into his own
series the problem with this was that
his own solo series was not very well
received and the result was that people
just did not really find it interesting
and so it only lasted something like 12
issues and then it was eventually
cancelled it actually ended up resulting
and I think with 2099 World of Tomorrow
which wrapped up a whole bunch of plot
threads and different things like that
but anyway guys this is the origin of
hole 20 on and on so I figured I'd go
ahead and fill it out there let you guys
check it out see what you guys think if
you are new here to come as explained
make sure you guys have the sub button
to become part of the robb core if you
guys enjoyed this video make sure you
drop a like and yeah I will catch you
all later peace
you